hey sorry I'm late that's okay it's a
match already started its game not match
is that white wine yeah Shiv I brought
red
oh not in my house can I get a rear AK
dude you are missing the entire game in
there hey I will come in at the
commercials guessing this isn't really
your scene being a non sports fan this
time your kind of sex people are talking
about the game fish you might as well be
speaking another language there's two
TVs everything is on mayonnaise on my
fantasy team huh
Tara Tolkien do you get him off the
waiver wire and you tell people you
don't want sports they just think you're
weird yeah my family just didn't watch
that much sports growing up did you not
have a TV or something
no I did or they think you're an idiot
gentlemen we are going to need a
full-court press on this okay Chris
full-court press it's a basketball
analogy it's where you pick up your
opponent at the baseline just means
added effort sometimes they'll just
pretend to be interested so people don't
hassle me the NFL are you serious
Flacco threw more than 4,000 yards last
season you look me in the eyes and tell
me that he's a better quarterback than
Angela oh Tom Brady good point no not
good yeah but why do you hate sports I
mean playing sports is fun but watching
sports is boring it has absolutely no
impact on anyone's life but how's the
sword says House of swords is totally
different that is characters that is
storytelling that is raw human emotion
so our sports
it's the narrative the team the players
dynasties rising and falling fortunes
won and lost in an instant sports gives
community identity and let's face it
sports have the best parties
they're basically tribal cults like
nationalism they cause fights riot chaos
it's medieval and not in a good house of
swords way exactly society needs that
primal release
you just don't like watching sports
because you aren't willing to face the
truth the human beings are just animals
no I just hate I just don't see why
anybody would get so worked up over
something that doesn't even matter
how some soul Lord has some sore Sunday
night have some swords run you little
[ __ ] run out of the cave God if you fix
our always great when the Ravens just
keep hanging out of Baltimore Ravens
wait a minute you don't watch house of
swords no I I fell asleep during the
pilot this is the most important thing
in culture right now that's a good show
it is exciting and it is heart-wrenching
there's a new world you get to look why
does everyone wear a vest because that's
their uniforms oh my god it is just like
sports
you guys like Gatorade idea Gatorades
pretty sick it's gonna electrolytes